personne n'est épargné par le variant
omicron pas même les enseignants au
grand dam de jean michel blanquer
quelques 7 % d'entre eux manquent à
l'appel dans les établissements
scolaires le ministre de l'éducation
nationale fait des prévisions pour le
moins ambitieuse est ce que je veux nier
que le mois de janvier difficile bien
sûr que non le mois de janvier est
difficile ils y allaient situation que
vous décrivez qui sont bien réels et qui
sont compliquées est-ce que nous sommes
démunis par rapport aux problèmes de
remplacement c'est le principal sujet il
est impossible de dire quel sera le pic
d'absence mais ne devrait pas dépasser
normalement 15 % un taux bien en-deça de
celui avancé par le conseil scientifique
fin décembre l'organisme entrevoyez
qu'un tiers des enseignants au mois
pourraient être touchés par le commis 19
d'ici à la fin janvier de manière
directe en étant en cas positifs ou
indirecte en étant en cas contactez le
nouveau protocole sanitaire mis en place
par l'exécutif est censé éviter cette
hécatombe encore faut-il réussir à le
suivre si un élève est testé positif
toute la classe doit faire un test puis
un autre deux jours plus tard et un
dernier après quatre jours un système
très compliqué à gérer pour les parents
d'élèves qui plus est révélé seulement
dimanche soir par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale depuis lundi la
rentrée des classes se déroule sous
tension voilà des enfants qu'on doit
faire des autotests ce que vous imaginez
des enfants de cinq six ans quatre ans
furent les autotests les parents leur
faire faire
et derrière des attestations ce bonheur
nous allons faire cours dans des bocaux
acolytes entendez ce talent qui sont
souvent tu as érable
avec parfois des températures assez
faible c'est très compliqué des masques
qui sont mal portée donc oui ce voilà
nous ne sommes pas du tout confiants
garder les écoles ouvertes à tout prix
c'est l'argument principal de jean
michel blanquer mais sans enseignant
c'est plutôt compliqué pourquoi afficher
temps de confiance alors eh bien parce
que le ministre de l'éducation nationale
estime que les professeurs font partie
des catégories de professions les moins
touchés par l'épidémie ce qui était vrai
un temps mis omicron a changé la donne
du moins si l'on en croit l'exemple
britannique une étude du bureau des
statistiques nationales du royaume uni
un organisme gouvernemental
paru ni les sambre indiquent-elles
exactement l inverse le coefficient de
risque relatif d'être testés positifs au
co vide pour les personnes travaillant
dans le secteur de l'éducation et de
0,38 un coefficient supérieur à zéro
indique une probabilité accrue d'être
testée positive par rapport à la
catégorie de référence en l'occurrence
les adultes actifs ne travaillant pas
dans l'enseignement des chiffres qui
n'ont rien de rassurant les enseignants
auraient souhaité une fermeture des
écoles ou une rentrée décalée au vu de
la vitesse de la propagation du virus
pour tenter d'éteindre le feu jean
castex a annoncé la distribution de
masques chirurgicaux à tous les
personnels enseignants le premier
ministre précise attendre un avis des
autorités sanitaires sur une extension
de l'utilisation à des masques ffp2 une
réaction beaucoup trop tardive aux yeux
des syndicats
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais qui arrive
bien tard puisque l'épidémie a commencé
maintenant il ya près de deux ans deux
ans pour que enfin une décision soit
prise on nous explique que on ira
jusqu'à 15% d'absence mais on y est déjà
il fallait absolument prolonger ses
vacances en attendant que la vague
épidémique se calment l'a finalement on
entendait l'autre jour jean castex
tapait très violemment par ces mots sur
ce qui propage l'épidémie cette épidémie
eh bien c'est ce sont les décisions
ministérielles qui actuellement la faune
galoper pour reprendre les termes du
premier ministre s'obstiner à garder les
écoles ouvertes est une chose mais à
quel prix telle est la question